- This is Pamela Rae Schuller.
She's a stand-up comedian,
and we're about to watch stand-up
that's medically relevant
and she's gonna explain it to you
and I'm gonna explain the jokes.
Let's get started.
- I am fully medicated now.
Anybody else, antidepressants, medication?
- I don't know how I feel
when comedians make that joke.
- Why?
- You shouldn't ever be upset
that you're taking a medicine,
but celebrating that you're taking it?
- No, it normalizes it.
How many people are gonna
see this and be like,
"Oh my gosh, I don't need to be ashamed"?
- Yes, but then how many people
are gonna request medicines
that they don't yet need?
- And then it's up to people like you.
- That's true, that's a lot
of weight on my shoulders.
- Doctors.
- Well no, it points to the fine line
between breaking the stigma
and not spreading misinformation.
- Or celebrating who she is
and what she's going through.
- I'm not anything against celebration.
- I thought I was on an antidepressant.
It turns out I'm not.
It turns out I'm actually
on a mood stabilizer
that they use as an antidepressant.
Fun fact about prescription drugs,
everything they prescribe,
they actually use for
four different things.
- That's true,
and not only do we use it
for four different things,
some don't even have an FDA
approval for those things,
like they haven't been adequately studied,
so we use them off label.
- I know that,
because I've been on so
many meds for Tourettes
that are not for Tourettes
because a study showed that
it might help Tourettes.
When I was 12, I wore the nicotine patch
'cause there was a study.
- Did it help?
- No, it just made me jones.
- Okay, well we had to try something.
You're out of control otherwise.
- So you don't really
know what your deal is
until you find a combo that works
and then Google all
your pills by yourself.
So after years of trial and error,
I finally found a combination
of things that worked for me.
- I don't want people
to try it themselves.
- Yeah.
- Because a lot of these medications
have really bad interactions,
so you have to have a thorough knowledge
of how they interact with each other.
If a patient of mine is on
three psychoactive medications,
I get them a psychiatrist ASAP.
- Okay, that's smart.
- Because there's so many interactions
that I'm not well versed
enough to know how,
to have the experience to
know how they interact.
- That's important.
- And six months ago,
I decided to Google it,
'cause what the hell?
And it turns out that
everything I'm taking
is primarily used for bipolar disorder.
So I went back to my
psychiatrist and I was like,
"Hey.
"Do we think?"
- We.
At least it's team based.
- And she was like, "Oh, yeah."
- They never had that discussion before?
- That's terrifying to me.
How many things do you think
my therapist thinks I have
and just hasn't told me?
- But why would they not tell you?
Do you ask?
- All the time, she'll
write something down
and I'll be like, "What are you writing?"
- But see, I hate labels,
because the labels aren't really
for the benefit of the patient.
They're for the insurance
company, the legal stuff.
But really, a person is not a diagnosis.
- So I agree with you 100%.
I think so often, especially
when we work with kids,
we're always trying to find a diagnosis
instead of getting to know
someone for who they are
and treating symptoms
of things we're seeing.
But I do think sometimes
knowledge is power.
- Do you think it could become
a self fulfilling prophecy
where you think, "I am X
so I must behave as X"?
- Yes.
- See, that's also.
- Yeah, but I, yeah, yeah.
- So it's individualized.
- It's a balancing act.
- I said, "You really didn't
know that I was bipolar?"
And she goes, "No, of course not.
"We thought we were treating
anxiety and depression."
And I said,
"Okay, 'cause this kinda feels like
"a putting your dog's
medication in cheese situation."
When I was in high school, I was like,
"Dad, I think I'm depressed."
And he was like, "You
just need some protein.
"Get a scoop of peanut butter."
- That's every health
influencer on TikTok.
Health influencer.
- I think, yeah.
- "Buy my protein!"
"Buy my hormone!"
You think I'm making that up?
- Mine would be amazing.
- Yeah?
- Do you wanna buy some
of my hormones, Mike?
- Yes.
But yours aren't hormones,
they're horny moans.
- No.
- Stand-up comedy, ay.
- No, you're canceled for that.
There's a reason you're a doctor.
- Yeah, who makes jokes.
- Yeah, there's a lot of dads out there
just white-knuckling it
through life right now,
clinging to a jar of chunky
Jif like it's the answer.
Just a buoy in the storm.
"It'll pass."
- That's a joke with a lot
of medical meaning behind it.
- Tell me more.
- Men will oftentimes
experience their depression
or show their depression to the world
in different ways than what
we describe traditionally
in medical stuff.
So for example, some
will develop addiction
to going to the gym, to taking
steroids and getting huge.
Some will get a gambling addiction.
Some will become abusive
in their relationship.
But really, what they're
experiencing is depression
and they're acting out.
- Look at me, learning.
And that was interesting,
so I was actively listening.
- Yeah, that was good.
I don't know if you were faking it,
you're a really good actress.
- No, you know when I'm faking it.
- Okay.
- My doctor comes in.
He doesn't say hello, he
doesn't say good morning.
He just walks in.
He points at me, which
is super aggressive.
- Are doctors ever that aggressive to you?
- Sorry, he is so my type
that that's all I'm hearing.
- Oh really?
Smash or pass?
- Oh, smash.
- And he goes, "Do you want
something for your hair?"
And I go, "What?"
And he goes, "Do you want
something for your hair?"
And I go, "I don't get it."
He goes, "Has nobody told you
"that your hair is falling out?"
And I was like, "Damn, no."
- It's a doctor roast.
- I went my whole life
being okay with my face
and then a doctor said,
"How do you feel about your weak chin?"
- Well maybe you should do some squats.
- And he goes, "You weigh 245."
And I go, "Yeah, I knew that (censored)."
And he goes, "You weighed
230 last time you were here.
"Not exactly what I
would call weight loss."
And I'm like, "Are we at a
(censored) roast or something?
"What are you doing?"
- Old school doctors
used to think this works.
- Then he says, ""You know
you're the fattest patient
"I've seen all day."
- No.
- And I go, "It's 9:30 in the morning."
- No way.
- I would do a murder.
- He's like, "You know,
we ran your blood work.
"It turns out, your muscle
enzymes are through the roof."
And I go, "Yeah, man, I'm super strong.
"How's that a problem?"
- Well, muscle enzymes happen
when there's rapid
breakdown of the muscle.
- Okay.
- It's a condition called rhabdomyolysis.
- Spell it.
- R-H-A-B-O-D-O-M-Y-O-L-Y-S-I-S?
- Ding.
No, I'm just kidding, I don't know.
- I don't know.
The myoglobin that's released
actually can be nephrotoxic,
so it's problematic to your kidneys.
This happens when people who
don't exercise for a while
go and start exercising.
- [Pamela] Oh okay.
- Or if people are found
down, like elderly people,
for a long period of time and
their muscle is breaking down.
Or if you take a lot of
drugs and you shiver a lot
or something like that, where
you overuse your muscles.
- Do you use words with your
patients like nephrotoxic?
- When I say nephrotoxic,
I follow it up with kidney
injury immediately after.
- My brain was still
stuck on necrotophics.
- "Do you have a ring on your finger?"
And I go, "Yeah."
And he goes, "You're married?"
And he goes, "To a guy?"
And I go, "No."
And he goes, "Oh, I thought you were gay."
And I go, "Why?"
And he goes, "Hey, I'm just kidding."
And I go, "That's fine."
He goes, "But check it out."
And he takes my chart
and he shows it to me
and he had written "gay?"
on my medical chart.
- I really feel like
this is a joke or a lie,
because a chart is a medical legal record.
You're not gonna write "gay?" on it.
- Yeah, it'd be exclamation point.
- Unless, unless, unless, unless,
unless he saw that Tom
Segura is a comedian
and he tried to be funny
in a really poor attempt.
- To doctors out there, don't do that.
- Yeah, don't do that.
- But people ask me dumb
questions all the time.
I'll get this one a lot.
They'll be like, "Hey
Ryan, is that genetic?"
"Yes, because you see, my mom was Irish
"and my dad was a lobster."
Kids are the worst though.
Oh, kids are the absolute worst though,
'cause kids don't have that filter.
If a kid says you're ugly,
you're ugly, all right?
Deal with it.
Buy a hat, I don't know what to tell you.
But this little girl, after she saw me
and after she screamed, she screamed!
It was a big scream,
which, side note, has led me
to a new game that I play.
Now when I'm out in public
and I see a child staring at my arms,
I like to pretend that
I'm discovering them
for the first time.
- I do that too!
Someone on the subway
recently goes, "You're short."
And I go, like, "Where'd
the rest of me go?"
- For four years, my wife
and I couldn't get pregnant.
- Oh, I've heard this.
- And it was my fault.
"What's going on with you and Beena?
"You're like Indian Barbie and Ken."
And I'm like, "I know.
"And much like Ken..."
- What, 'cause Ken is plastic?
- Has no...
- Yeah.
- I have art in my apartment,
this is very much Pam art,
and it's Barbie and Ken in a motel room
and Barbie's on the bed
and Ken is standing there
and they're both naked Barbies,
and the caption just says
"Disappointed Barbie".
- Aw.
- A lot of doctors are my age,
and they're Indian, which
means I might know them.
So we're sitting there in the
waiting room at NYU, right?
Door opens, nurse comes out.
She's like, "Doctor
Gupta will see you now."
I'm like,
"Oh, this better not be
Arjam Gupta from Sacramento."
Then I hear a familiar voice.
He's like, "Hasan Minhaj?"
I'm like, "This is Arjam
Gupta from Sacramento!"
- Is that his boy?
- They went to middle school together.
- He's a (censored) idiot.
He's not even an MD.
He's a goddamn DO!
- Why is he so angry about that?
I never understood this joke.
- He burned you through the computer!
- Yeah but why?
- So this dude is all
up in my merchandise.
He's like, "Aw bro, I know what's wrong."
I'm like, "Stop saying bro."
He's like, "Son, oh.
"You got too much blood down there.
"It's lowering your sperm count.
"So we're gonna do a dangerous surgery
"called varicose seal repair."
- A varicose seal is basically
a swelling of your veins
in your scrotum.
We used to say, if you feel that area,
it feels like a bag of worms.
Can you think of a more poop explanation?
- Thank you so much for that visual.
- That's what they taught
us in medical school.
- This dude pulls out
a trimmer and he goes,
"Let me shave you down right now.
"Let's do this right here, right now."
I go, "Arjam, back up.
"I'm not ready."
He goes, "Listen, man, if
you don't get this surgery,
"you can't have kids ever."
Are you serious?
Life gets very real when
don't want becomes can't have.
Isn't that right, DOs?
- He's so anti-DO, which is
funny because in this clip,
the DO ends up allowing him to conceive.
- Yeah, to be clear,
I'm not at all anti-DO.
- I don't think he's anti-DO either.
I think he's just making a joke.
- [Pamela] Yes.
- But it's just at the cost of doctors
in the midst of a pandemic,
when doctors were on the front lines.
- That's totally fair.
- Terrible!
Look, as a comedian, you
gotta know comedic timing.
- Yes.
- And if you're gonna
make a joke about doctors.
- When was this filmed?
- Peak pandemic.
- [Pamela] Okay.
- My dermatologist said
he needed to do a biopsy
of a little mole on the tip of my nose.
- I was about to say,
you don't need a
dermatologist in some cases.
I can do that, but not if it's on the face
'cause I'm worried about
scarring and stuff.
- Wow, that sounds like it's gonna hurt.
He said, "Don't worry,
we're gonna numb it first
"with a painkiller."
I said, "How?"
He said, "We're gonna
puncture a sharp needle
"into the tip of your nose."
- When I work with patients
and they need a small procedure done,
sometimes I say I think it might be best
to go without anesthesia,
because the anesthesia might
hurt more than the procedure.
- I had to get a little thing removed
and she did the anesthesia,
she gave the shot
and then she started slicing
and I started immediately
crying and yelped.
- You have to wait.
- And she goes, "Well it
takes 15 minutes to kick in."
And I was like, "Then wait 15 minutes!"
She was annoyed that she had to.
- When I did my derm rotation,
you would inject patients with lidocaine,
move on to the next patient,
figure out what's going on,
go back to that patient, do the procedure.
- Uh huh.
- And at the hospital, I said,
"Excuse me, can I have pain medication
"'cause I am not thriving?"
And the nurse said, "Oh
okay", and he gives me the IV
and he gives me a little
pump of something,
and I was like, "Yum yum
yum yum, yes she's alive!"
And then I was like, "Actually
no, I still passed away.
"What the (censored) was that?"
And he said it was a placebo,
it was a saline injection.
And I said, "Sir, my ankle
looks like a (censored) U-turn.
"You better give me some
(censored) (censored)."
And I don't know if you guys know this,
but black and brown people
are prescribed opioids
at a lower rate than white people,
so white people have a higher
addiction rate to heroin.
And I said to myself, "Huh,
maybe sometimes racism's good?"
- I will say, it's a double edged sword.
Let's say you're in a community
where I worked in Newark.
You had patients that'd come in
that you know are at high risk
because of their environment
for developing an opioid addiction.
If you're a good doctor, you should know
that if you live in a
white suburban community,
you're also at a high risk.
- Okay, good, yeah.
- But being aware of someone's risks
and tailoring their medication
plan is actually good.
So in this case, the
doctor that's assuming
that because someone's white,
they have a lower risk
is factually inaccurate,
and therefore has led to worse outcomes.
So it's when biases work against you,
not when racism works for you.
You get what I'm saying?
- I do.
Before major surgery,
I asked if I could get
something to take the edge off.
I already had an IV in and I was like,
"Can you give me a little
something something?"
We're running late, I was
freaking out and they said no.
And then I started
barking and then I got it.
Then it went from a scary
day to such a fun day.
I was telling jokes.
I did stand-up for everyone.
- I would've rather you called me
and I would've just held your hand.
- That would not have helped.
- Some people will say I'm a medication.
- Okay, they're lying.
- I started walking in my sleep.
I was living with my
girlfriend at the time
and I started having a recurring dream
that there was a hovering
insect-like jackal in our bedroom.
- I had the same dream, but it
wasn't a jackal, it was you.
- That's because I was there.
- Oh.
- I was just like.
- I did buy a book, it was
called "The Promise of Sleep"
and I learned that there are
78 known sleep disorders,
things that range from sleep apnea
to night terrors to narcolepsy.
Narcolepsy is terrifying
'cause there are people who
fall asleep at any time.
- I think there's more than 78.
- Sleep disorders?
How many do you have?
- Primarily one.
- Insomnia?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, anxiety induced, mostly.
- And I read about this thing
called REM behavior disorder
where people have a dopamine deficiency.
That's the chemical that's
released from your brain
into your body when you fall
asleep that paralyzes your body
so you don't do what's in your brain.
- Interesting, I don't
know if that's 100% proven
or the leading theory.
Basically, when you fall
asleep and you enter REM stage,
your muscles are supposed
to become paralyzed
so you don't move during
this stage of your sleep
while you're dreaming.
- That's why I don't hit REM.
- Oh.
- Tourette-ta-Tourette-Tourette-Tourettes.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- So do you not feel
refreshed when you wake up?
- Not very often, no.
- Five years ago, I'm in
Walla Walla, Washington
and I'm staying, which is a place,
and I'm staying at a hotel
called La Quinte Inn.
And I fall asleep and I have a dream
that there is a guided missile
headed towards my motel room
and there was all this military personnel
in the room with me.
I jump out of bed.
So I decided, in my dream, and
as it turns out, in my life,
to jump out my window.
- Oh no.
- There are two important details.
One, I was on the second floor.
Two, the window was closed.
So I jump through a window
and I screamed "Ahhh!"
- And it's not like one
of those action movies
where the window gets blown
up before you jump through it.
- No, yeah.
- He's literally flying through a window.
- And I got up and I kept running,
and I'm running and I'm slowly realizing
I'm on the front lawn of La Quinte Inn
in Walla Walla, Washington
in my underwear bleeding,
and I'm like, "Oh no".
- What does it say about him, maybe men,
that it took him literally
jumping out of a window
to be like, "Maybe I should
get some help for this"?
- Well that's literally
what I was gonna say.
When people ask me
when is the time that you should
see a doctor for something?
That's the time.
- I would say one day before that.
- Yeah, but it's hard
to predict sometimes.
But that's the definite line.
- And the next morning,
I flew back to New York
and I did what I should've
done in the first place
when I saw the jackal.
I went to a doctor who
specializes in sleep disorders
and I was diagnosed with
REM behavior disorder.
And so now when I go to bed
at night, I take medication
and I sleep, and I'm not making
this up, in a sleeping bag
up to my neck and I wear mittens
so I can't open the sleeping bag.
- There's gotta be a better solution.
- That sounds so comfortable.
- No it doesn't.
- Yes it does.
- Struggling to escape?
- I love small spaces.
Wrap me up like a burrito.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- With gloves that you're unable to open?
The problem is, as a single woman,
they would then find me six years later.
- That's literally what I do to babies
when they scratch their faces.
- And then when you unzip
babies in the morning, they go.
- Like I said, I have Tourette Syndrome.
- The best one!
When I'm with other people with Tourettes,
I pick up on their tics.
That's pretty normal.
So you're about to see
my Tourettes gets worse
when I watch him.
- Oh.
Camera, watch intently.
- This twitch gets me in trouble.
My roommate came home from work.
I was like, "Dude.
"Our neighbor died."
He said, "Did you kill him?"
I was like, "Nah."
- That's the same as your pick-up joke.
- No, it's my customs joke
where he asked if I'm
bringing anything illegal
back into the country
and I was like, "No."
- Click here for when Pam
reads thirsty tweets to me.
Enjoy this one, follow Pam
and as always, stay happy.
- And healthy and fabulous.
- Yeah.
(light music)